so we just saw what an outsourcing
conversation might look like what
includes the entrepreneur a designer and
a developer I want to pull out a couple
of parts of that conversation for us to
focus on here the first is a tendency
towards scope creep scope creep is
whenever the first version of your app
isn't the Minimum Viable Product scope
creep is bad it gets in the way of
launching and iterating which means that
you're spending a lot more time building
things than building the right things as
an entrepreneur you have to make sure
that your team isn't introducing scope
creep but you also have to make sure
that you aren't introducing scope creep
scope creep affects both time and budget
in the consultation we just saw Carl did
a very good job of managing the scope
creep and he was the one who suggested
that we pare down RV one of the app in
real life that job will fall on you this
idea of scope creep is especially
noticeable in the pole between the
developer and the designer James wanted
to spend some time at first working on
the overview page making it gorgeous
Karl noted that that was actually a
waste of time for this Minimum Viable
Product another tension you may
experience is a designer wanting to
build things custom without thinking
about how long it will actually take to
build them as an entrepreneur you need
to be balancing budget with the time
spent by your contractors a good rule of
thumb is to launch your minimum viable
product without anything custom or fancy
if you can avoid it once wrap to started
getting feedback in customers you can
make it as fancy and beautiful as your
designer wants until then stick to the
default components